- Bacon my favorite. I ain't gonna lie.
Buckeye's be hitting though.
What's up? Its your boy C.J.
Out here with bleacher report.
Usually y'all see me on Saturdays here,
On back, looking at tailgates,
having a good time and
supporting my Buckeyes.
(crowd cheering)
I miss being at Columbus,
everybody so nice and welcoming.
So got a lot of love out here for people.
I appreciate it.
It's a lemonade so, you know,
first bite of some fire.
Buckeyes be hitting though, for real.
What time is it?
Nine in the morning?
[Tailgater] - It's 10:14.
- Ah, ain't no barbecue at no 10:14.
But it looks good though.
It's cool man. It's not
something I would want to do.
I wanna go play.
(C.J. laughs)
- This is for noon game
so when it's like you
need a good breakfast.
- Okay, thank you
'cause I went to another spot
and they have barbecue.
- Yeah. Like not it yet.
- Nobody's eating barbecue,
you know what I'm saying?
- You can have just bacon.
- Bacon my favorite. I ain't gonna lie.
- [2nd Tailgater] Got
it from this farm too.
- For real? I need to talk to you.
I'm trying to have a farm
in these next couple years.
(crowd cheering)
He caught that easy.
(C.J. laughs)
We gonna mess up the recruitment.
Nah.
- It was my unofficial visit,
my first time at Ohio State.
October 5th, my birthday weekend.
I flew from the game
and I flew with my ankle tape on.
So it's kind of a crazy story.
Like I got to the team hotel
and I asked for scissors
because I had to cut my
ankle tape off from the game.
So, nah, that's good memories, man.
That was my first time ever in Columbus.
Q was the alley-oop guy, for sure.
They owe Q a lot of money.
(Q laughs)
Talk me through it, little bro.
- So, I didn't really set it up.
- Okay.
- But I know someone that did.
- What you got yourselves?
Some brisket? That's
brisket right there? Okay.
- These wings are unbelievable.
- Oh okay.
When do y'all prepare all this food?
The night before or this morning?
- This Morning.
- This morning. Wow.
You gotta get up early.
- Yeah were here about six o'clock, 5:30.
- Wow.
My preference of a tailgate?
I don't know.
I feel like I like this type of stuff
but I couldn't eat any
of this in the morning,
so I would prefer like more breakfast.
But like a night game,
this one would be perfect.
How's everything going?
It's good to see you.
What's up bud?
Good to see you, bro. How you been?
- Good.
- I miss y'all, man. Is your brother here?
- Ah no.
- He didn't make it?
- Yeah
- He gonna be mad.
- Yeah.
- It's Juicy, right here.
Everybody meet my guy, Juicy.
- [Crowd Member] Thank you so much.
- Love you, bro.
How you balling?
Man, I've been out of this
tunnel a thousand times.
First one as like a
spectator, so I miss playing
but you know, support my guys.
What's up with you?
(crowd talking)
- Man, I'm so fucking proud
of you. I miss you, man.
- Ahh.
(both laughing)
that man, the myth, the legend.
- JuJu.
- How you doing, brother.
- Snakie.
- Hello, baby.
- Love you, bro.
Kid X.
- How you doing man?
- Okay-zy, bro.
(crowd talking)
Good to see you, man.
- Thank you.
- How you doing, man?
- Hey, how are you, man?
- Good to see you, man. Thanks, man.
- Thank you. Thank you
for sorting that out.
- So man, I'm going with the Buckeyes.
I think we'll come out
and win this thing a little early, man.
I definitely think our defense
is gonna maybe even go with a shutout,
so I'm definitely going
with the Buckeyes, man.
(crowd cheering and booing)
Yeah, go ahead. Boo.
(C.J. laughs)
Nah, it feels good though, man.
To be back home.
See all my brothers.
Man, it's blessing.